[Music]
so what do you guys think
about the k-pop look i love it
what's that what's k-pop book uh or like
the asian
mail oh dante has opinions you have
opinions okay
get cancelled right now see yeah no no
no it's cool
it's cool i think when i was younger i
would have been like down with i mean
watch out for the armies dude i'm with
my brothers like at the bosch brothers
being a band growing up
we were like born into a boy band so i'm
with that but
this is a different generation there's a
different generation and now when you
look at
it like we grew up with like new edition
new kids on the block and then you went
to nsync and
backstreet boys but you know they are
the same look you just see asians doing
it i kind of get a kick out of it i just
saw him on the uh
the videos of bts yeah i mean
you know asians do it big it's like yeah
america we got like
five guys we know the five guns don't be
like twenty dollars the the
to the tough one the you know we know
the guy that's too old for the group but
he's in there
but when the asians do it they got like
they got every troll 12
yeah 20. yeah it's so many but then also
the music videos too are
so like in captivating i'm like whoa
they're all wearing makeup too but
i mean i mean the guys are wearing
makeup you know you're done i mean
you got the registry that way yeah but
i'm not trying to wear makeup every day
that's a lot that's like it is a lot but
i mean it's not new right like dude's
been made wearing making
makeup appearing like in the 80s and
[ __ ]
it's just not for everybody but they're
also going hard they're contouring
yup mm-hmm they're like the eyebrows you
gotta get them
they gotta get them right they got they
have a new member of the boy but
it's like kind of like the trans member
we don't know that's true
that's kind of cool like they're yeah
they're evolving yeah
they're very ambiguous they have so
they're like 31 they're like baskin
robbins of boy bands right
it's like they even bring like the fat
one and then
it's like the unattractive one and then
like everyone is there
a lot of them are non-korean too now are
they yeah yeah like k-pop doesn't really
i thought they had like at least some
sort of korean thai
i mean there's no i'm saying like in the
group that'll be one korean whereas
before it'd be like everyone's korean
like when i was in junior high but then
now it's like there's a good chinese guy
and there's a thai
thai girl or he's like that is filipino
yeah
but they all have to learn korean yeah
yeah
you said you liked uh the look what do
you what about the look do you like i
think i really like that they just came
into the space and they created their
own like little universe
like yeah like k-pop it's its own thing
like they revolutionize
just music all around like there's a lot
of there's a lot of different countries
that come in and then they try to adopt
the western style of everything because
like
the western style has been number one
but k-pop was like
not korean yeah we're doing my own thing
and they [ __ ] smashed it i love it
it's i [ __ ] they created their own
definitions and it wasn't almost
it's almost like you know a lot of
people they kind of create their
parameters and they kind of explore
but for them they already had very
detailed
like creative direction on exactly what
it is because i grew up in cerritos
there's a lot of koreans and i've been
seeing
like full-on k-pop [ __ ] since i was like
10 11 and that was stuff that i
completely didn't even understand
was it was it the same then as it is now
yeah ass blonde hair all up in the face
like this
remember them dudes dj doc and then they
had the tl they always had haircuts like
from tlc
yeah like that like edward scissorhands
looking [ __ ] like
if beyonce had a haircut k-pop dudes
were copying it oh really yeah that's
funny
that's why it was kind of fun yeah it
was kind of funny back then what do you
ask
well i asked because now chyna has been
getting
in on this like pop scene
there's been yeah
[Music]
chinese pop looks like a cirque show and
it is the craziest thing
yeah man like it is it is its own thing
i saw one time a performance a man was
in a peacock outfit
and i thought i was watching like you
know hunger games when the
when the athletes come in and they're in
these crazy ass costumes and stuff
he was doing a whole performance like
that hella off key
but it was just like really dope yeah
sea pup is it's not my thing
also i haven't seen those c-pawns i see
j-pop i haven't seen no c
growing up growing up c-pop to me was
like andy low and [ __ ]
yeah well that's like there's already an
established c
pop but i kind of feel like what you're
alluding to is
boy band like copying the cake pops all
right well
that was f4 okay wasn't there like a
chinese band called f4
fu f4 i remember it was like one
f 24 there was like 24 members f-24
isn't that where people work out
f45 i think it is my friend works there
all right so we all know kpop is known
for uh
you know very petite you know boy
look boys charm i mean they're asian
yeah it's true
but you know they're known for they're
very they're very skinny physique and uh
very contoured faces i thought they were
buff
oh well some yeah i know you're right
you're not all of them but bts for
example like being like the kind of the
poster child of this
uh i mean none of them remind me of vin
diesel no they're not that's true that's
true no no no no
no but more like soccer players but then
i probably don't watch enough k-pop to
understand
i just remember people had posters of
them and i'm like
oh [ __ ] dude these guys are pretty
ripped for asian guys
and they are they are and then it was
like um i don't know if they're k-pop or
korean actors yeah i don't know
but yeah so in china they've come out
with a new boy band
uh i'll tell you the name but uh is it
corona related
no there's not corona coronavoice thank
god it's not corona
but they're basically coming out as a
antithesis
to k-pop in a sense that they're trying
to go against the grain
of being like the the frame
they're called they're produce pandas
produce pandas and they've embraced the
chubbier dad box okay dad bought it's
like just chubbier on the face
you know stockier wait what was that one
band do you guys remember it was this
chinese band they came out and they were
making like chinese trap music
yeah they're signed an idiot rising uh
something i was listening to for a while
i like them but i thought that was cool
too like they came out really different
yeah that was that was really cool and
there was like different like there was
like a chinese guy
there's like a fat shirtless guy yeah
yeah that one's my favorite the singer
the father that was cool why are they
called produce i get the panda power
produce like
well they like grocery store produce or
they produce
oh maybe like producer like producer b
is it produce me
or is it a double entender like cabbage
and carrots and stuff
it might be because they sing about
eating oh i love food man
so so here's some a couple pictures
here's uh maybe oh
it's like a parody band are they a
parody band i think so i mean they're
talking about food all day and they're
embracing their fatness in the k-pop
style
true they're not even that fat well not
parody but like jokes you know they're
all like the fat boys
don't put them to the american standard
bro because that's some [ __ ] up
that's true their idea of fat and their
idea of buff is different from ours
yeah that is true when i first saw the
photo i was like i don't get it
they're just average they're like
average yeah they're just called like
whatever dudes that looks like
[Laughter]
whatever dudes don't need two all right
have a little we should start a band
with everybody whatever it is i have a
little snippet here here we go yeah one
second they're orange belts there we go
that's their average dude i was an
orange belt too as high as i got one
hand
[Music]
chicken feet
[Music]
i wonder if uh ken just choreographed
this
oh yeah my mic song do this
they got studios out there yeah i know
they're fun
i like it yeah i think it's dope i do
have to say though like
the difference between what comes out of
asia when i was in high school
and junior high versus now is so
different
i'm hella like happy with the content
that's being
out of there but before it felt like
info
and style and all that [ __ ] went to asia
a little bit too
like 10 years later 10 years later
because like my
parents generation the way that they
took like jazz and american music
and then made it japanese style was so
[ __ ] sick
and then um i don't know but then like
come the 80s and on
it was really [ __ ] weird man and i
was like man you just trying to copy
and it's so lame the way that they did
it right it was like a pop version
of like watching western culture and
then just stealing it and then doing it
really bad
like they were off beat they had really
bad skills and i was like what the [ __ ]
dude this is so weird
and they got stuck in the 80s for a long
time yeah
it was stuck like now i think we all can
just see stuff
in real time and it's not like we're
waiting to get that
but now the [ __ ] that's coming out of
asia is so sick like they
take the stuff that they learn but then
they also put their own twist on it and
i'm like that's pretty dope
i also think that's just part of the
development like you kind of have to
like put out a bunch of shitty stuff and
then eventually like you find your voice
it took them like 20 years but they did
it dude
they did it to be on regular radio and
hear like a bts song or one of the bts
guys with like an american artist
just rapping in korean on american radio
why
i'm like dude we never you might hear
some spanish songs
you know what i'm saying lighter shade
of brown or something
it's
that was like in the 50s or something i
only know the american version
the original came out as a hit in
japanese
really sukiyaki yeah the only one i know
is the voicemail yep
i know that too of course that was the
first gangnam style no idea what the
song is
that's a little gangster because that's
like that's like that's part of the you
know the oldest show that was like our
grandparents generation
yeah we listened to that song i love
tsukiyaki yeah
that was gangnam style back in 19
whatever
60 years number one asian hit first
asian hit huh it's
old yeah yeah first asian hit on the am
radio yeah
now we got one of the guys i don't know
but i don't know the names of bts you
know like we knew the names of all the
other boy bands
there's probably james park in there i
know do we know john lee
probably none of them is it because
we're old because like
i think so new kids on the block we know
the names of them
[Music]
that's before me okay in sync i know all
of them
that was my generation but i refused to
learn that what other
generation you are have a boy band you
gotta know the name of the boy band guys
i thought it was too cool man yeah i
only like [ __ ] like old classic rock
[ __ ]
yeah so no instinct no now i love it but
like growing up you know you didn't want
it
no you were definitely not true and now
i don't mind listening to the backstreet
boys
i was the perfect age to be about that
[ __ ] because that was 11
when they came out i think that's pop
seven yeah
and like 12 7 and 12. like that was my
instinct time i think our version of boy
band was easy e dr dre
that's true true that's true like that's
what all i need when you look back
it was a boy band you wouldn't think
about it like that but now this is the
boy band with different colors yeah yeah
and different intense different outfits
different different intent they have
their own gimmick
yeah i feel like i was allowed to listen
to pop until
uh the end of elementary school and in
junior high and on
if you still listen to pop people are
bullying you yeah you can't and then
unless you're a girl or whatever that's
true because i i
in eighth grade is when i started going
more towards like my rock
scene yeah i moved away so in junior
high you're supposed to be like oh [ __ ]
mainstream
no i i would classify it as rock i guess
i don't know it's rock rock classic rock
cause i like system of a down and sink
i mean what like that's alternative
instinct is a hard
rock band like i don't know lincoln park
i mean that was like more alternative
but
lincoln park yeah yeah you look you
think of it now you think i was hardcore
back then you're like that's super
no even back then i didn't think it was
hardcore when you're in the midst of it
though you don't i remember when lip
biscuit came out i [ __ ] loved it
they're so corny well some saw they're
corny now but like there was like
certain signs were dope i just thought
it was dope like the whole hip hop and
rock going like that
i thought it was so cool yeah i thought
it was so tough was great
it was like screaming it was like water
damn screamo
yeah exactly i think it's and water it
on wrath
yeah what do you think about the wraps
oh the wraps i'm not like the rap i mean
i like like a bark i like you know yeah
hybrid theory is my favorite hybrid
theory is great what happened to some
41. my favorite part my fav
is there they're uh the one with jay-z
the the
mash-up album they did that was really
really tight
that's great